la décision est tombée en fin d'après
midi berlin stockholm et varsovie décide
d'expulser simultanément un diplomate
russe en poste dans leur pays
une réponse à la décision de moscou ce
vendredi d'expulser trois employés des
ambassades de suède de pologne et
d'allemagne pour avoir participé à des
actions illégales le 23 janvier dernier
jour où s'était tenu de nombreuses
manifestations non autorisées en soute
cher alexeï navalni réagissant dans la
foulée le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères a condamné ces expulsions la
décision prise aujourd'hui par la
pologne l'allemagne et la suède est
infondée et inamical ces expulsions
s'inscrivent dans le prolongement de la
série même d'action que l'occident mène
à l'égard de notre pays et que nous
qualifions d'ingérence dans nos affaires
intérieures
des mesures qui interviennent quelques
heures après une déclaration du chef de
la diplomatie européenne estimant que sa
visite à moscou le 5 février dernier
avait mis à jour que la russie ne veut
pas saisir l'opportunité d'un dialogue
constructif avec l'union européenne
étonnement au kremlin d'autant que josep
borrell évoqué lors de sa conférence de
presse dans la capitale russe un
dialogue ouvert et franc sur un certain
nombre de sujets dont le soutien de
bruxelles alexeï navalni si personne ne
l'a limité ni dans le temps ni en termes
de format peut-être après être revenu à
bruxelles le chef de la diplomatie
européenne at il reçu des
éclaircissements concernant ce sur quoi
ils auraient dû mettre l'accent mais
dans ce cas là cela ne fait que
confirmer par qui et comment est élaboré
dans les faits la politique européenne
le 22 février prochain
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
lieux s'entretiendront pour décider
d'éventuelles nouvelles sanctions contre
moscou une décision qui nécessite un
vote à l'unanimité des états membres de
l'union
bruxelles reproche à moscou deux refusé
d'accéder à sa demande de libération d'
alexeï navalni ce que la fédération de
russie considère comme une forme
d'ingérence dans ses affaires
intérieures